all right hi my name is Dan and I work
at Facebook on the react team and in
this talk I want to talk about the
future of react and originally when I
planned this talk I thought that I would
talk about react 16o release and then
the upcoming react 16 free release which
finally fixes the contacts API and then
talk a little bit at the end about the
future of react but I was playing with
some features that my teammates have
been building like future features some
of them we've talked before some of them
we've never even talked before and I
realized that I actually want to
dedicate my whole talk to these new
features that aren't available yet but I
find them pretty fascinating and I hope
you like them too so disclaimer I'm
going to show the demos this is a very
kind of demo oriented talk the things
that I'm showing are not production
already yet the exact api's will change
don't fixate on them too much but I want
to emphasize that this this is a real
builds of react so there's enough fake
journals these are using actual actual
react code and I want to start with a
question and the question is as library
developers we need to think about our
immediate users the developers who are
building apps and also the users of our
users that is the actual people parties
in those apps and so at Facebook our
scale is pretty global so we need to
consider all kinds of connections and
all kinds of devices such as you know
high powered CPUs like on a laptop or
low powered CPU such as on the mobile
device and either fast or slow
connections and we need to think about
how can we as library developers empower
the application developers to give the
best user experience regardless of the
device or the network and is there
anything that we are can do better to
enable them
so when we think about those issues we
tend to group them into two different
areas the issues related to the
computing power and the differences in
the computing power and the different
the issues are related to the
differences in network speed and I'm
going to refer to this as CPU and IO and
in the context of react when we think of
the CPU work you usually think about
creating the Dom nodes creating
components rendering them updating them
calculating the updates and so on so
things that are tend to be synchronous
and when we think about the i/o work in
the context of react we should think
about the data fashion and the code
splitting so is there something that we
I could do better in those areas I'm
going to start with the CPU area and I
have a demo as I said this is a demo
oriented talk so this is my demo if
maybe it doesn't look like a real I have
that T built but at least it's pretty
beautiful and it's graphic so it's
easier to see from the audience but what
I have here is I have a tax box I can
type into the text box
hello yes come and I have a bunch of
charts and every time I type the charts
update and I made it so that the longer
I type the more complicated the charts
become so this lets me show that no
matter how fast the implementation of
component is eventually if the component
tree is deep enough and there are enough
Dom nodes there is enough computation is
going to slow down and I don't mean to
nitpick us on a specific like chart
example the you can imagine that instead
of a chart there could be any kind of
react component tree so the main point
is just that it's a heavy tree with a
lot of dumb notes a lot of components
and it updates every time I type and so
already with this level of complexity
when I type I experience color
and I'm the one who experiences it
you're probably maybe you don't see it
so I build a small clock so the clock
shows the how how the screen updates so
when the when the crate sorry when the
clock is green it means that the last
frames are were drawn pretty near to
each other so it feels responsive but if
you see when I type I can see yellow and
even red this means that it takes a lot
of time between different frames so the
user experience suffers and eventually
no matter usually no matter what kind of
app you're building eventually you're
bumping into this problem where no
particular component is slow but you
just have so many features and such
deepness then that you have this problem
so the typical solution to this is to
debounce the input so instead of
updating the updating the output
immediately as a type I can just wait
until the type and finishes and then do
a single update so I can type the the
input is completely responsive but then
the user experience suffers in the sense
that if my computer is actually powerful
enough so like I will remove some
characters to make the the the
complexity smaller I still have to wait
until to finish typing to see the
results so this program doesn't really
adapt to the performance of the of my
computer and to the complexity of the
team and this is even more pronounced if
I enable the CPU throttling so CPU
throttling is a way to emulate
performance of a mobile device of a less
powered device so I will slow down the
CPU by 4 times and now you can see that
even so a type which is called Iceland
and even though you waited a little bit
it still froze the underlying
it's just that the update is big and
it's synchronous so as soon as the react
starts rendering it cannot stop well
what if there was a way to make updates
asynchronous so that reactive starts
rendering something but then healed back
to the browser and if there is a higher
priority event like an input the browser
could handle that first and not started
a thread so I will disable the throttle
thing for now let's see how it normally
behaves in asynchronous mode so what you
can see here is that when the input is
short and it doesn't there is not a lot
of computation in a base almost
synchronously so it feels like as if it
were synchronous but if I type more what
happens is that instead of hanging the
thread the thread says responds if you
can see that it's most agreeing but
instead we actress updates the chart
it's left less often and the elect
behind my input a little bit but in many
cases this actually doesn't matter and
it's a completely fine compromise from
the UI perspective let's see what
happens on a slow device so I enable the
CPU throttling four times slower
you can see that it does starter a
little bit but it's mostly green and it
tries to catch up to of my typing even
though the device is slower compared to
the synchronous version where it just
stutters on every keystroke
of course in real apps you often can
optimize updates specifically so maybe
only part of your app updates and so you
can just update those components and
avoid a large update but not every there
are also scenarios where you just need
to mount and you have a tree so I will
unmount this chart completely and then
mount it again with froth enabled so
that's simulating a slow device and you
can see that it hangs every time and
while it's while it's rendering the
chart
nothing is interactive so I can actually
click on this clock to simulate an
interaction but while it's mounting it
doesn't register my clicks now
debouncing doesn't help us here because
d bouncing is only helpful for updates
but here I'm just mounting a huge
component tree so let's compare this
with asynchronous mode and I still have
the throttle and a enabled so that's
emulating the slow device so in
asynchronous mode you can see that even
though it Strutters a little bit it
doesn't go into red and interestingly
the circle stays interactive so I can
actually I can start mountain I can
click on this interact with this so the
whole app is still working while the
rendering is mounting in fact I can even
start typing in the input and it's going
to update to my type in so that was the
CPU demo
[Applause]
and I want to emphasize that this is not
about the charts or the inputs we've
built a generic way to ensure the high
priority updates don't get blocked by
low prior to update and in this
particular example high priority update
was updating the input and a low
priority update was rerender in the
chart but it could have been any kind of
react component for example a feed story
that gets loaded and we don't want to
freeze the scroll while we'll load in
new items and defeat and we call this
feature time slicing so it doesn't block
the Frog the thread while it's rendering
and if my device is fast enough it feels
almost like it's synchronous but if it
is slow then it feels at least it feels
responsive so it adapts to the device
thanks to browser exposing a request
idle callback api that we use for that
also notice that only the final state
was displayed the update the rendered
screen is always consistent we don't get
artifacts of slowly rendering something
that is going to cause a junky user
experience we only flush when the low
priority update is ready and you might
think oh maybe I changed those chars to
like make it's probably a lot of work to
make charts this chart component worked
like this but actually I just used it a
ready-made component from NPM
I didn't make any changes to it so we
can look at the code and it's just a run
a regular render method I have a chart
component it renders components from NPM
I pass data to it and I call set state
and I use a special flag to tell react
that it's is a low priority sad state
and personally I've found it very
helpful to use version control as a
metaphor for this so when I didn't know
about version control and I would just
modify the files as I've worked on them
hopefully I never like did anything
silly that I can't undo so I would just
work on a feature in my application but
then if suddenly in the middle of
working on that feature I need to fix a
bug now I can't do it because I only
have one version of my tree so I have to
finish working on the future first and
this is kind of how react works without
time slicing the react that you know is
that it can't interrupt the lunk update
but when I learned version control I
learned to work in a branch so I could
start working on the feature working it
in the branch but then if I need to do
an urgent bug fix I just do it and
master and then I can rebase the branch
on top of that and so this is pretty
much how react works with time slicing
except that you don't have to rebase
anything and react does that work so
reactive term is how to apply a
low-priority update on the top and it
can continue working and then flush when
everything is ready just like I can
merge the branch when it's ready so
we'll look at what we have could do
better at the CPU side what about the
i/o data fashion and code splitting I
have another demo that's that's the fun
part
[Applause]
all right
I built a movie app so you can see this
is the app it has a list of movies I can
click on a movie
it shows the detailed page were with
movie details and the reviews and that's
basically pretty much everything that it
does so it has an app component at the
top the trenders either movie list from
movie list page which is this page or
the movie details page which is this
page so there is just to kind of pages
here and the data is currently
absolutely hard-coded so there's like a
Jason with with the array of those
things and we take the data by ID from
the Jason so what if I wanted to change
that to fetch data from a remote API
let's go to the movie page component I'm
going to remove the hard-coded movie
details trace and import and instead I
will import fetch movie details from API
alright and I'm going to use another
function that I'll import from the
future again the exact API doesn't
matter it may change most likely so I
will call it create fetcher for now then
I'll go through the movie details
component so currently movie details
reads from JSON object but I'm going to
do something different I will create
something called a fetcher so I'll call
it movie details fetcher equals create
fetcher and I will pass my promised
return the function fetch movie details
through it now the next step is going to
be a little bit controversial so if you
know react you probably know that you're
not supposed to do data fetch and in
renderer so in this talk I'm going to
ban this rule a little bit and I just
want you to follow along with it and see
where it leads us so when react came out
it was pretty controversial
I think we can make more controversial
things all right so I have this fetcher
object and it works as a cache it has a
single method called read so I'm going
to call movie details fetcher that read
and pass the ID so what's going to
happen is that when a reactor enters the
movie details component it will try to
get this data from the cache but the TV
is not there because it's not fetched
yet
so reactor is going to fetch the data
and Rehab is going to prevent the entire
update from occurring until the data is
ready there is just one more thing I
need to do I need to tell react that is
actually ok for the transition from this
page to the details page to be
asynchronous so again the exact API is
probably going to be different but here
in the movie click where it says state
show detail true I will call something
called differs at state with the same
state so let's see if that works I click
on an item it waits and it loads and if
you don't believe me I actually built a
small debugger here so it shows the
pending requests and how requests happen
so if I remove everything from the cache
and I click on the movie there is a
request here and when it comes back
react renders the detail view now you
might think oh there must be a race
conditions and maybe you think that the
screen is not interactive well as
fashion no it's it's interactive I can
click here I can click here it's going
to load the right one now it's in cache
I can go back I can click on this movie
it's in cache so it renders instantly
however what if the latency is high what
if their network request takes a lot of
time like in this example three seconds
but it could have been like 15 seconds
so now if I click on a movie it seems
like nothing is happening if you don't
have the debugger open so that's not a
very good user
we can improve it so I'm going to import
something else from the future it's very
convenient to have access to the feature
I'm going to import the component called
a placeholder and I'm going to say that
if anything inside the movie page is not
ready we're gonna render a placeholder
if the movie page takes more than a
second and a half to load so there's a
delay milliseconds argument then I want
to show a spinner
so what we are is going to do is going
to try to render this component but if
any of its child is going to render as
much of the tree as it can but if any of
the children are waiting for a single
dependencies is going to wait for those
children and if it takes more than this
amount of time is going to display the
for the placeholder until those
dependencies are resolved so let's see
how this works
I click on a movie in this case my
default latency is 1 second so it
actually feels almost instantaneous so I
don't see the loading indicator but if
the latency is high 3 seconds and I
click on a movie then it shows the the
placeholder and then it shows the real
thing when it's ready here is another
interesting thing even while it's
showing the placeholder the app is fully
interactive it is never frozen so I can
pause all new requests start a fashion
imitate the fetch it takes a long time
but say I want to go back I can actually
go back so the whole the screen is
always interactive now which has fetched
the details but what if we want to fetch
the reviews as well to do that I'm going
to back to movie page component and I'm
opening the let me import remove the
hard-coded chase on import and instead
import fetch movie reviews and I'm
scrolling down to my movie reviews
component that currently reads it from
Jason and I create movie reviews fetcher
great fetcher with fetch movie reviews
and again I just call read I said sorry
movie reviews fetcher dot read for props
idea
so move your reviews and movie details
are siblings but the reality is going to
wait for both of them before continuing
so let's see if the latency is 1 second
is waiting for both but wolf resolved in
time so it doesn't display any
intermediate loading states and doesn't
the page doesn't jump with spinners but
let's say that I pause near request a
start fetching
I'll let the reviews come through first
while reactor can't render reviews alone
it's important that the screen is always
consistent with what's in the render
methods so react is still showing the
placeholder but when the details of the
movie are loaded this is when it shows
everything together now this may be fine
but there is a downside what if I
actually don't care about the reviews
that much and I don't want to delay
showing the details if the details told
it first
well to do that I use the placeholder
component from the future so I can wrap
the movie reviews component in a
placeholder and I can say that if the
movie review specifically took longer
than a second to load since the
interaction we actually don't care about
them that much and we're going to show
another spinner with a medium size let's
see what happens so I pause all new
requests start loading a movie and allow
the details first it shows the details
but the reviews are still loading and
when the read is already it shows the
reviews and again there are no risk
conditions I can go back I can clear
this I can start fetching this start
fetching the reviews go back well here
start afresh in the details it knows
exactly what's the right thing to do and
it respects the props that I passed
through it but we can still make the
user experience better for example when
I just click if the delay is less than a
second
it's nice that the screen pops in when
is ready but before that happens I don't
have any visual indication that
something's happening
so can we fix that yes I will go into
the app component and I will import
something else from the future
it's called loading so this is not the
final API this actually this API is most
likely to change but for now loading is
just a component that gives me a render
prop cold is loading that lets me decide
what to show for now I'll copy paste
what I already have here
so either the detail view or the
ListView but I already prepared my movie
list page in a way that I can pass a
load and ID through it and it will show
an inline spinner so for example if I
pass loading ID equals 1 it shows a
spinner like this if a passcode and D
equals 2
it shows the spinner on the second movie
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make loading ID and argument to render
list and I'm going to call render
released so if we are currently loading
which is what we wanted to ask react
then I just pass the current idea
otherwise I pass null and I can even
remove the the main placeholder now
let's see what happens so now when I
click it shows an inline spinner and
again no race conditions I can click
here then click here it shows the right
thing the screen is always interactive
and now this is cached
so this is all cool but we can still
improve the user experience even further
for example currently we show the the
movie page below the code for the movie
page right away but we don't actually
need it until we click on the movie so
I'm going to replace this with a
component that does code splitting so
I'll call it movie page loader and I
define it above it takes the props and
passes them to movie page so if we are
code splitting do we need to show a
spinner while the code is loading or
does a question even make sense if we
have these new primitives that's him I'm
going to import create fetcher again and
I will create a movie page fetcher to
fetch the movie page I will use the
dynamic import syntax so I will return a
promise that returns import to movie
page and I remove the static webpack
import so it's not going to be in the
initial bundle finally to get the movie
page component I call the read function
on the fetcher and read the default
default property from the module because
it's the default export so I'll see if
that works I click here there is no
global loading indicator if the request
takes fast enough
yeah just edit code split into my app
but if the request is slow oh I guess I
removed the fallback so yeah that's not
gonna work but we can check that this
actually did something so if i refresh I
clear the network top and I press you
can see that there is a chunk here so
you can see that this component truly
was loaded with collision there is still
one improvement to the user interface
that I can make her
you might have noticed that this movie
has a taller posture than other movies
let's say that we don't know their sizes
immediately so when I click on it for
the first time the page jumps a little
bit when they when they movie loads so
can we avoid showing the page until the
image is ready well we can go to the
movie page component and find the movie
poster component that renders an image
and I will create my custom image
component with capital I the choice
renders the browser image except with
the twist I create an image feature
which is a fetcher now I need to return
a promise so return a function that
returns a promise that resolves when I
create a browser image object to preload
the image and what that image loads I
resolve my promise and I started the
loading process and now I say that the
source is image fetcher that read prop
source I'm bad at this right yeah this
should be an argument because I pass it
to the wreath so it's going to come out
here now if I click on it that didn't
work okay it's a live demo some things
don't
oh right I forgot to use my image
component that's why you should let look
at the lint warnings so let's use the
image component now I'll click on it and
jumps on the page when the image is
ready
and this was the IO demo
[Applause]
we've built a generic way for components
to suspend rendering when they load
asynchronous data or dependencies or
really anything asynchronous and we call
this feature suspense you can pause any
state update until the data is ready as
specified by the components and you can
add agent load into any component
anywhere deep in the tree without
clumping all the props and state and
hoisting it up and using readouts or
anything you usually do for that and on
a fast Network the upside is that you
can make it appear very fluent and
almost instantaneous without the cheran
cascade of spinners that appear and
disappear all the time but on a slow
Network you you can be intentional about
design in the loading States and not
just let them be artifacts of how the
code is written in study explicitly
design which load and States you want
the user to see and how brenner
of course they must be and there is both
a high level and a low level API so the
API that I showed you is a high level
reference implementation that we're
going to provide but there is a lower
level API that libraries can use to
integrate with this and again I found it
helpful to use version control as a
metaphor so when I use version version
control and I start working on something
and do this on a branch but sometimes
maybe I can't continue working on the
feature because I'm waiting for the
designer to give me the final design so
I put that work aside and I can do
something else and this is how react
suspends works is that react knows that
these some of the children need some
async dependencies so it just suspends
that tree but it can still handle a
higher priority event so this is why I
was able to click on everything and
continue navigating through the app and
later just like I can rebase my old
branch when I finally have the designs
on top of the master react rebuses they
suspended update
and can continue when the async
dependencies are satisfied and then
committed to the Dom so coming back to
my question how does how can a reaction
able better user experiences for people
with different devices and different
networks we think that time slicing
helps the CPU case and the the saucepans
feature helps the i/o case is that we
can be more intentional about designing
for slower devices and how they should
behave but we can also provide better
experiences of past devices and you can
see that there are a lot of similarities
between these two these two axes so this
is why we don't really think these are
separate performance problems we think
that both the problem the main problem
here is not the performance but
scheduling and the solution has to think
about the scheduling and so we call this
see the features async rendering in
react and our goals is to let app
developers adapt to users constraints
such as device and network to make fast
interactions feel instant without the
janky things popping out of the screen
and make slower interactions feel
responsive and we designed intentionally
and importantly this is still the react
you know this is still the component
declarative component paradigm now if he
is reactive you probably that's what you
like about it so it's not ready yet but
these are not fake product like you saw
me really using it so it's a real thing
there is a pull request for this and
there is more work to be done
to enable this and to ship this as a
stable feature and we hope to deliver it
this year thank you
you